حيث نفى الجيش الاوكراني حدوث اي انسحاب
جماعي لقواته من مدينه باخموت بمنطقه
دونيتسك شرق اوكرانيا وقال المتحدث باسم
المجموعه الشرقيه للقوات الاوكرانيه
ان الجيش الاوكراني لا يزال يسيطر على
مدينه
مضيفا ان القتال يدور بشكل اساسي في ضواحي
المدينه
في المقابل اعلنت سلطات دنيا لروسيا مقتله
مدنيين واصابه اربعه في قصف اوكراني على
مناطق متفرقه بالمقاطعه واضفت سلطات دونيت
كان قصفا مدفعيا وصاروا خيان اوكرانيا
استهدف مدينه غور لوفكا واحياء في غربي
وشمال دنيا مضيفه ان القصف ادى ايضا الى
تدمير عدد من المباني السكنيه ومنشات
البنيه التحتيه
وفي خرسون اعلنت الاداره العسكريه
بالمقاطعه مقتل شخص واصابه ثلاثه في هجوم
الروسي على احياء سكنيه واتهمت هيئه
الاركان الاوكرانيه القوات الروسيه
باستخدام المدنيين في منطقه
نوفاكا خوفكا الواقعه على نهر دينيبرو
دروعا بشريه من خلال وضع الدفاعات الحيويه
في الاحياء السكنيه